Hãy tên phố sau chung tâm vụ bụi anh chính công ưu tiên hỗ trợ sắc là bắn bị quyền với người thủ hợp
có tổ sung kích lên ngành duy tri hỏng đợp để hướng giản tiên nhận hủ sơ, chứng thực sự kí tại diện tập chung thong tổ giấn phố
Họng cạnh nhà với người có công các tuổi, yêu thế, sức khỏe iấu, họ hành trong đi lại.
Chung tâm tổ hợp bằng rao zang sách giải quyền của em cho phía bưu điện.
Để chuyên đến các quan bảo hiểm sã hội cập nhận và chi trẻ theo quy định.
Tạo điều kiện tuổi đã đi người hưởng không phải đi lại nhổ lần.
Bởi người hưởng mất ngăng lực dân sự hỏa khó khăn trong nhận thức mà không làm được quyền.
Thì người chăm sắc duy dữ ủng làm đơn đỉnh nghi đục nhận chí độ.
Họ sắc nhận của chiến quyền định phương cơ quan bảo hiểm sà hội tiếp nhận hủ sơ
và chi trẻ lương hư chựa các chung người hưởng.
Đứng người hưởng không còn thân nhận không nơi nương tự ở năng sống tại các cơ sở nùi dữu tập chung
mà mất nhận thức thì có sở lắm bản đỉnh nghi ý các quan bảo hiểm sà hội chuyển tiên lương hư chựa các thằng tháng.
Châu cơ sở đăng chực tiếp chăm sắp nùi dữu hưởng.
Chương hợp nơi hưởng năng sĩ sống tại nơi cơ chú mà dởi quyền còn thử 1.
Không còn nhu cầu thấy đổi người nhận quyền.
Thì phía bảo hiểm sáng hội cân cơ dân sẽ có sắc nhận của chiến quyền định phương.
Để dưới chiều lực dấy đại được chứng thật để chí tra.